luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we are going to take
25 bucks down to walmart and see if we
can buy everything we need to survive in
the woods
in the rain in the cold
do you think we can do it yeah
all right so me and jacob are here at
walmart we got our 25 budgets and i've
got nathan here with me who's given
moral support
and we're going to go inside walmart and
see if we can't get all the equipment we
need to do some winter survival camping
tonight all right
[Music]
[Music]
87 cents
[Music]
all right 292.
[Music]
all right we got 532 for bagging hand
warmers
all right hands down the cheapest
mattress they have is 797
and it's for the ozark trails air
mattress
for 10 bucks you can get the 50 degree
bags which are very thin and they're
also an adult size
or
you can pay as much as 36 dollars for a
20 degree bag
i don't know about this getting two
sleeping bags for me and jacob it's
going to break this budget
well the sleeping bags aren't going to
cut it so we are going to get blankets
here so we're going to go 588 for this
90 inch blanket
all right now that i've spent my budget
it's time for jacob to spend his all
right jacob you want to buy your
survival stuff yeah okay what do you
want to get first
[Music]
do you want
the fuzzy tiger blanket yeah
you want a furry blanket too
i'm not going to thank you
the animal print is 496 and the fuzzy
one is 8.88 what do you want to buy next
for your survival trip
[Music]
you want a great white shark
oh my goodness
look at that what is this
is that gonna be good for your survival
trip yeah okay
now jacob you have four more dollars do
you want to get another blanket
no
it's going to be 32 degrees tonight you
sure you don't want another blanket how
about a knife should we get a knife
all right let's get a knife
one knife
oh jacob i think we have two dollars
left what do you want to get uh
you want a t-rex
197 for a t-rex
there you go
we got our survival shark and our
survival t-rex well there was some
dubious budgeting by half of our team
but
we've got our stuff we've kept within
our budget time to go test it out
okay the official amount on the receipt
5228 and there was 2.78 cents worth of
taxes
so
we came in under 50 and popped over on
their taxes
i asked jacob to spend his budget on
survival gear and that's what he bought
[Music]
oh boy keep my baby warm
yeah we'll see how this goes i gotta
pack up his survival gear
well we're here but it is cold it's a
high in the low 40s today and it's
supposed to get down below freezing
tonight so i'm gonna dress jacob up nice
and warm before we head off into the
woods
well i don't have a backpack
so we're gonna have to improvise
survival t-rex
another fuzzy blanket that is your shark
bottle of water
hot pads there
wow
all right you back there jake
well we're about two hours away from my
house and on a piece of property where
i'm working on a pretty big project
i'm building an off-the-grid
blacksmithing forge we got a lot of
other really cool projects going on here
too hopefully you guys will get to see
that pretty soon
first things first got to bust my knife
out
dang it i really need a knife to get the
packaging off this knife the blade is
inside the knife and i need to undo this
little screw
to get it out luckily my key is kind of
working
i just bent that key
aha
got it
come here
all right we got a knife and the first
thing we need to do with it is open up
survival t-rex
there we go
now we can survive in the woods
well guys i kind of made a big mistake i
forgot to buy matches or a lighter or
anything for making fire so
we're gonna have to dig deep today
luckily i've got a little bit of a cheat
when we went camping last time i wore
this jacket
and i left some cotton balls in my
pocket and i used cotton balls as fire
starter and they work fabulous
but i am going to try to make a fire
using a cotton ball the first thing i'm
gonna do
is try to gently unwind
this cotton ball it's a little mangled
though that's about as good as it's
gonna get
i'm gonna take a little bit
of this fire ash
and do is going to roll this sucker up
we're only going to use about half of
that
and save the other half just in case
and uh
you go like this
i'm gonna roll that
nice and tight now we're gonna turn this
into fire using nothing but elbow grease
but first i gotta get some fire starter
and kindling and tinder and all that
stuff we got one shot
we don't want to blow it because we're
not ready
all right i'm gonna need some very fine
dry tinder to take an ember and turn it
into a flame and i like to use cedar
bark you can see this right here
this is a cedar tree and it's got this
this fluffy bark here
it's like paper really fine paper almost
and it's got loose bits you can just
peel it off it doesn't hurt the tree
but look at that it'll take an ember and
turn it into a flame so quick this is
great stuff to have if you like to use a
ferrous rod or flint and steel
there we go that is a perfect pile of
tinder you know it hasn't rained in
three or four days so this tinder's bone
drying will work very well
that's why you kind of got to gather it
and store it whenever you can because if
it was dewy or snowy or been raining
this stuff would be garbage so you
really you got to grab dry tinder and
keep it dry whenever you can i need
something flat
i've got this flat log i've got my
little bit of cotton ball now we're
gonna rub it back and forth until we get
smoke
[Laughter]
all right here we go
yeah got a little
see the lamber there now i'm going to
take this
i'll put this in there i'm gonna blow it
[Music]
sharks eating a t-rex
oh you are having a good time one thing
i'm kind of uncertain about is how i'm
supposed to blow up this air mattress i
uh i don't have a pump
and uh well we'll just
we're just gonna see what happens
looks like some sort of valve that
electric pump is supposed to go to guess
we can do this old-fashioned way
[Applause]
oh i can already tell i'm not gonna like
this
oh
okay
well before i sit on this i need to
clear out every stick every thorn every
twig
i can't have this thing popping on me
what happened to your foot
it's in a hole
i think it was a counter
oh
there you go
[Music]
hey jake you want to see if you fit on
this
we're gonna have to share this thing
it's gonna be a tight fit jake
get you
is that nice
no these aren't very big they'll be big
enough for you though
climb under these blankets with jacob
and kind of get a feel for how much
trouble we're in tonight
you like this
i think we're gonna have an interesting
night's sleep oh no shark attack
well the weather forecast says we got
some rain coming so i need to get that
shelter up and that tarp secured but i
forgot to buy any cordage
so uh we're gonna take my little box
cutter here and see if we can't figure
something out
got this really thorny blackberry bush
here oh these hurt
there we go there's some cordage
there we go teeny tiny little pup tent
it'll keep the rain and wind off us and
maybe keep us a little bit warmer
okay i had some grand plans for my
cordage but uh
turned out didn't need it anyways
why is that
i got some of these free ketchup packets
from the gas station here and wow we're
gonna put them on our hot dogs and uh
we're gonna roast ourselves some wieners
yeah you want to cook your own hot dog
yeah okay
all right you want me to cook your hot
dog for you yeah okay winner no
campfire hot dogs are hard to beat
this has actually been a really low-key
camp out with only 25 bucks worth of
stuff i haven't had to pack a lot of
things or prepare fancy meals it's uh
actually been really uh really relaxing
so
i'm actually kind of kind of looking
forward to this
even though i'm a little nervous about
being warm and dry
it's getting late so we are going to get
ninos in bed
all right let's see how best to do this
you know what we need to do we need to
put some hand warmers you want lots of
ham warmers
do you want one on your stomach yeah
okay i thought you might want
there you go
well it's a little tight in here but uh
it's warm so far
but it's supposed to drop a good 15 20
degrees tonight and get below freezing
so hopefully we'll stay warm think he'll
be okay jacob
yeah
yeah well we'll give it a try
it's about 10 o'clock and uh the rain
started
and it sounds really crazy on the
tarp but uh we're dry a little warm and
jacob's asleep so
let's see how this goes
well it's 2 a.m and it's been raining
pretty much non-stop for the last four
hours
and uh it's starting to soak through the
tarp
so far jacob's still warm but man these
blankets are getting wet
we'll see what happens all right good
night
well it's 5 30 in the morning and the
rains finally let up and uh despite the
leaking tarp and all that i'm pretty
warm and dry except my feet they're just
soaked and cold
jacob's doing really well and uh
so i'm gonna go try to get the fire
started warm my feet up
i gathered up a bunch of that cedar bark
yesterday and stored it away in my
pocket so i've got some dry tinder thank
goodness
so cold
oh yeah
we got cold
i threw a bunch of big green logs on the
fire because they wouldn't burn up that
fast and
it looks like that's paid off
i didn't think my hands were that cold
but i'm trying to build this fire and
they're just shaking
oh
yeah i do not fit on a twin mattress
that feels real good
i'm getting a little hungry so i'm going
to pop out some leftover hot dogs and
went over to grab him and pour little
jacob's half off his mat so i scooted
him back on and
he seems to be sleeping soundly so
that's good
now that i'm warm and dry i am so tired
i think i might curl up and take a
little nap here by the fire
well good morning it's a cold damp day
jacob's still sleeping really good under
the tarp and so
i'm just gonna let him go as long as he
wants i think i might make some
breakfast here a little bit
oh there's a jacob stirring
is that my jacob
hi buddy
are you cold yeah you warm
you like to come sit by the fire with me
yeah okay here
oh you have a good nights for us yeah
oh good
listen are you hungry do you want a
hard-boiled egg
yeah boots stayed relatively dry
well
my little ridgeline pole completely
failed in the night yeah this whole
setup was a failure
pretty much all the stuff i did with the
sticks and stuff completely failed and i
just ended up using the tarp like a
blanket that's all right it worked
but uh
our little two dollar tarp kept us
pretty dry we really needed it
oh
oh my head is soaking wet
yeah here you go here's your survival
shark
[Music]
check it out
last night we got some snow
i thought that rain sounded kind of hard
yeah
it really was wet and cold last night
all right jake you ready to go home
all right let's do it
well guys thanks for watching we hope
you enjoyed this if you want to see more
great outdoor camping and adventure
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
and check out our camping adventure
playlist we have about 40 different
survival camping and camping videos on
there some pretty cool stuff we'll see
you guys next saturday thanks for
watching
and don't forget to click subscribe if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]